sylvette comment ça va motiver gecko
tonnes le vendeur
[Musique]
on est fort j'adore regarder
regardez c'est ça qu'on veut c'est de
l'éclater voilà c'est sur le côté
non mais c'est sur le côté c'est
françois fillon si en fait il est
devient sur le fc bourrac émane
j'adorerais faire 7
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sois non mais non mais toi mais toi
tu as ta beauté une belle qualité de
cheveux moi je fais moi je fais ça ça ne
fait pas du tout ça fait pas du tout je
te lis et la réédition de l'album 7
puisque c'est ton septième album album
on suit les choses on est là il ya une
info la donne ims attend c'est que ces
produits là qui fait ça qui fait ça
j'aime beaucoup mais c'est aux london
j'aime bien féroé il faut non parce que
c'est là normalement je vous écris que
le délire c'est normal mars à la halle
existe en noir et yallo vendeur il fait
il n'avait pas sa taille en noir il faut
qu'ils b prend lambèse ça va avec tout
[Applaudissements]
il a plu
merci
bravo
mais là
avec ton et en direct mais chérie tu
veux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aux badauds
g
[Musique]
iv
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
tu plais
la vérité pour nos téléspectateurs quand
vous étiez pompiers est ce que vous avez
déjà eu une ouverture et vous avez
conclu
dites moi pas loin on n'a pas le droit
mais bon on est aussi on n'a pas le
droit à ça va ça va c'est fini non sans
rigoler je le sais pas moi pendant
l'intervention
papandréou après alors comment ça s'est
passé après les numéros au québec
pendant qu'ils sont inconscients
[Musique]
le témoin un truc un peu conscients
bah on avait eu une intervention où la
demoiselle était plutôt que charmante
way et or partance était pas arrivé à
moi par contre leur partant elle a
demandé à mon collègue son numéro et
alors il n'y a pas de données voyons pas
les soirs pour donner alors il n'y a pas
donné ses barriques et des défauts
s'appelle justement pour faire venir les
pompiers on s'éduque sur moi j'étais en
campagne
d'accord donc c'était plus calme on a
par des chats adorent ya des gens qui
ont évidemment aussi c'est qu'il n'ya
pas c'est pas il se passe souvent ça
plus dans l'est quand ils brûlent les
voitures tout ça pour faire accroire
appelé les pompiers mais non mais non
ils vont brûler une voiture dans un
champ entre acteurs
[Applaudissements]
à
soit adoré quand on écoute les choses au
tibet allez je vous rappelle bien
entendu les chiens qu'on va se retrouver
devant demeurer une diversion alors à
l'aquagym avec aziz
[Musique]
tél
les chaînes pour trouver bien sûr à
20h45 vous aurez bien sûr une réunion
d'information et à des heures 15 mai sur
le tir à l'arc avec mini
[Musique]
à marrakech les enfants avec nous
tikitag bien sûr l'animation rachid et
mouloud
bon
c'est le repas